hey guys the Apple event is going on
right now it is kind of embarrassing if
there is a translator talking over top
of the actual announcement so I don't
know what the heck is going on I'm like
what what I can't understand what you're
saying based on participation
I feel like space jump all over again
holy crap Oh have to pee will get me
doing to me oh my god I'm shaking I'm
shaking I'm shaking
Oh a lot wait maybe this my works nope
Oh God
like this one goes out I got this one
Apple watch took very deep thinking
speak user-interface lose your mouth and
revolutionary product with the Mac we
introduce you use your words to make
navigation so she's gonna cut this out
you've gotta scare this bill on the iPod
allow users to scroll through thousands
of songs all iPod you changed my life
you don't need to understand all of that
I understand it it's good but it's very
very easy let me give an example
and you have a list you don't put them
on your desk or in your pocket if you
put all your arm on your wrist but I
really like that silver wristband or the
watch senses that you're raising your
wrist and then activates the display so
we've developed a whole new interface I
would do this for you to connect
intimately with others open one's
attention with a gentle tap and a press
pad provides instant access to of ocean
all combines on Mexico
look at you Matt that's awesome for
watching multiple 50 millisecond as Wow
the sport band symmetrically around the
wrist from different
every discipline at Apple one of the
compare this more four minutes in 39
seconds um right now we're waiting we're
having it waving out well god I think
we're heading up an iPhone 6 pretty hard
or party we'll be back
they say the Apple Store I don't know
we've got stations we've got one station
to station
that's species finder but there will be
who in there another station set up
another station do you have the the 18 T
side open - yeah it's doing a countdown
where Oh smart smart okay I'm just gonna
try to get what I can get wherever I can
get it
story in my life where's my tripod three
minutes three minutes three minutes
the doors are opening when it's your
turn this page will automatically
refresh with what you've been waiting
for
holy poo City on 18 G on 18 t just said
it just said it right now holiday teens
you know what I was waiting for how did
you know oh okay midnight who that is
midnight it says not to refresh because
I think we're in line oh wow what is the
first ones and why like nothing's
happening maybe I'll open Safari maybe
it likes safari better showed up really
yeah we were well looks like you can see
really yeah but there's only great
there's only sees gray oh no they're not
oh yeah oh my god well you may
easy-to-use making people move in here
anything I just oh my god over that
right up hmm I really wanted to order
from Apple but I will take whatever I
can get from the first I stopped
listening Xbox
not talking to you six-six I don't
understand why they started a 16 gig is
it not 32
I mean you service yours I mean you shot
your mouth
choose the model silver okay I think
wait okay friendly and available did you
tweet about it you did we weren't close
to tweet about it who broke the pact I'm
brushing there maybe I'll so pray for
the apples or I'm stress-eating